[Music]
in vaping news
I love vaping dude love it I'm still on
the pedal have you been before who me
yeah I've never been before
oh really it's like hookah this is just
like a big cloud machine yeah I see
about biggest [ __ ] clouds when people
blow it out yeah it just looks fun
I don't know that she looks do you
remember when wasn't illegal everywhere
because people didn't know what it was
yeah smells good yeah it's so like I was
able to do that poker tables everywhere
like yeah it doesn't matter
illegal know what's illegal like it has
the same laws as cigarette smoke yeah
you're vaping to me is just like the
same [ __ ] like I say about magicians
dude they come up to you the light then
you want to see something it's crazy
where they can make a tornado like a
bunch of donuts and one flies oh it's
even crazier now yeah yeah don't be
[ __ ] blowing carousels and [ __ ] I
follow this one that I just worked
because if you follow a vape tricks guy
yeah cause it's just so satisfying to
watch what does he blow [ __ ] railroad
track with the choo-choo train yeah you
get so high like millions of followers
dude you don't know his brother is a
sponsored vape trick guy what they make
these videos to music and [ __ ] like I
didn't know what the designs that they
can make it's crazy and then they put it
into [ __ ] bubbles and all this [ __ ]
and like it's [ __ ] nuts
it does sound like they get beat up to
them as well they should submitted by
mutter ding dong ding dong you guys jump
right on that and I was like I was so
confused even reading it alright the
e-cigarette brand Joule can no longer
sell fruity flavored products in stores
after an FDA crackdown oh my god that
makes so much sense because little kid's
gonna pick that up and be like they have
been it's a big thing in high school
right now right and middle school yeah
that's a good thing though because I
remember when I was in high
I smoked a Marvel reg when I was like 15
or 16 for the first time and like I
thought I was gonna look all cool like
about to smoke this and stuff and I was
like this is so [ __ ] nasty but if
somebody handed me that and I could
still like do the smoke and everything
but it was fruity I probably would have
kept some ice cool it was all about the
mouth the black and milds
the marble mouth you can click miles and
then send it in and then you could get
like jackets or things my uncle has all
that [ __ ] swisher Sweets smells so nice
you like my jacket my lung cancer black
your mouth swisher Sweets they all smell
so gooood a s'more really it's like
brown sugar I think I want to eat it oh
yeah somebody focus most wishes like a
snitch in black and milds cuz it reminds
me of like my party phase like when I
was in Virginia like we were like 18 19
I guess doing good everybody smoking
stuff you know let's light up a black
and milds like that's like sentimental
to me this just reminds me I like to use
it to roll blunts with everybody did
they just take the tobacco log you'd
never really smoke the black mom some
people did in Virginia we had that
doodoo weed we have that headache we do
do is ditch weed you guys had this week
mm-hm
does Isaac's friends got vibes and stuff
I don't know I want you should ask him
yet well I mean he's Elementary's always
that melts cool yet no next year you
would be a big kid they're saying that
nearly 12 percent of high school
students and three percent of medical
middles medical students in the middle
that sentence out I'm a middle old
doctor they're using Joule which is this
this vaping USB drive calling it the
apple of vape product which are they
yeah sure cuz it's invented by a guy
that wears a turtleneck stew and they
had three times as much as nicotine yeah
cuz they're gonna they're gonna get you
hooked they know what they're doing
exactly I think it's supposed to be like
for people that don't want to smoke
cigarettes and don't so then they take
one hit and then or two and then that's
it
you're not supposed to sit there and
puff it all day that's here and I'll
turn it in for adult smokers so it's
like to help people like wean off of it
get to wean off of it but because of all
these flavors like
mango and fruit medley and how do you
wean off of it if there's three times
and nicotine right I know all my friends
are like yeah I quit smoking I was like
not really bro
are you [ __ ] sucking on that [ __ ] all
[ __ ] day dude and we're talking they
should just say I quit smelling like
[ __ ] yeah that's basically what it is is
I use yeah it's like I quit tobacco but
they're still doing nicotine yeah that's
so true that I can't stand the smell of
cigarette and your breath is nasty your
hand that you oh yeah a lot of people
are saying that the reason why they
they're doing that they're jeweling it
up it's because it's so discreet it
doesn't smell and it just gives them the
hit that they need I think it makes it
easier to continue nicotine imagine
without maybe the health effects of the
lung smoke damage yeah but there's no
studies that possible cigarette yeah
long-term stuff you don't know yeah cuz
when I was um smoking vape and [ __ ] like
I hear like a like a sizzle right and it
it to me it looks like like oil like it
is oil it's like it's oil burning so I'm
like what's worse like oil burning or
just tobacco leaves burning oil burning
sounds worse right and in oil because
oil sticks to your lung yeah oh yeah
that's kind of crazy yeah so then
they're saying now that so first of all
Jul they have 75% of the e-cigarette
market oh just started in like 2015 good
for them they just got a ton of you know
users and so now they're saying that
they're gonna halt their like promoting
on Instagram and on Facebook I get none
of those ads that's good that's good cuz
you're not exploring cigarettes but they
still have to stop selling fruity
flavored yeah because the FDA demanded
for them to submit documents about its
marketing and research and what it and
how they are marketing to young people
because it's illegal to make you know
tobacco products look cool and make seem
like attractive to the younger is that
what marbled a stick to Cowboys and
stuff well that's the thing so sort of
the tobacco industry they can't do it at
all like that's illegal
but for e-cigarettes
they have like a whole nother type of
like loopholes that they can get through
because it's not technically like what
are the flavors like puberty pomegranate
there's a creme brulee like all this
look these are their fruits hardy
tangerine they're gonna stop providing
those flavors to brick or mortar places
and then for online orders they're gonna
have additional steps to verify age
because they know we don't get through
actually don't work verifying age if I
want to smoke
I've been 45 since I was 12 there's a
lot of baked stuff to where you can get
no nicotine or you can choose the amount
of nicotine that's in there but I don't
know about the Joule thing I never I
never I don't think has that because
they like one of the bigger things too
that they've announced is that they're
gonna try to come up with products that
have less nicotine but their amount of
nicotine is three yeah but the fact that
they put that three x amount and y'all
know that nicotine is a thing that gets
people addicted it's like I know what
y'all are doing exactly it's like even
if it started out as like I wanna like
you know get people to stop smoking and
oh this is kind of a cool thing well
then they started realizing oh [ __ ] we
making money by like marketing it all
people as possible they want people to
stop smoking and they want people to buy
their products same with the patch
industry they won't be able to stop
smoking so they could buy their patches
yeah and they ever want you to stop you
on the patch it's like secretly exactly
it's like don't smoke [ __ ] chew
tobacco here use this instead does the
patch feel good have you guys ever tried
the patch
no but it's I read I saw the contents
yeah it's a lot like it's [ __ ] all
like I saw a pack right like like that's
like people who smoke like packs of
cigarettes a day yeah it's a lot of
nicotine you know it would be cool
though if they had like like if they
actually wanted people to stop smoking
and you could sell a [ __ ] load of these
if you were like hey we're gonna sell
you a program you have six months or 12
months to stop smoking and it would
slowly wean you down or something if
they ran a bunch of tests on that and
sold it like that but they want you to
keep smoking it like past a year yeah I
wish I wasn't a digger to ice-cream man
that she gets me dude I block in my
icecream stores I start itching its
I [ __ ] love icecream back to the
South they found out that ages 15 a
little ice cream ages 15 to 24 did I
scream Jul yeah they did not know that
it contained or 19% of them didn't know
that it contained nicotine at all what
the [ __ ] did it think it had candy yeah
they just don't know it all together the
Stoke smoke they're [ __ ] stupid
there's like so many kids that are using
this 24 is not a kid and if you didn't
know there was nicotine in there you're
a [ __ ] dumbass I just I don't even
know as I guess a parent my kids are
just like vaping and [ __ ] I just gotta
ask it was like why
what's also psych um the problem that
people have to deal with is more of us
like psychological problem than anything
because of nicotine leaves your body in
48 hours it's completely out so your
body's only going through withdrawals
through the brain it's like gambling
right like gambling it there's no real
like biological effect that the gambling
does like it's not that it's what it's
how your brain gets pleasure from the
gambling hmm and then so the nicotine
chemical is gone within 48 hours but
then your mind is now so conditioned to
rely on you know having nicotine in your
body so it's like I need it I need it I
need it I think a lot of it though too
is just like it's a reaction to like
anxiety and what people don't realize is
when you're smoking a cigarette or
you're smoking a babe you're
accidentally controlling your breathing
you're doing a five-second inhale and a
five-second exhale and some people don't
even realize that you're kind of like
meditating then or just doing a
breathing exercise which helps anxiety
and then they kind of confuse it with oh
this is the cigarette well it's also the
way that nicotine works is you get a
little bit of poison right so then you
know that feeling when you get a really
painful massage but then after it feels
good cuz you're that's why people feel
relaxed is because you take that hit and
nicotine you get that dose of poison
it's a stimulant it wakes you up and
then as it's leaving your body then
you're feeling relaxed because you're
slowly getting that poison out and then
it's like I need that poison again to
feel relaxed from that poison put like
this yeah we could put us
this somebody who vapes needs to get
cancer boom Oh Lucien solution there's
not enough Studies on it it might happen
once that one [ __ ] gets cancer
problem solve and the video now I don't
know no but it's like so because in the
u.s. they set like they were pretty much
eliminating youth tobacco use through it
through the years that goes going down
all they're doing a good job of it but
then jewel comes our like products like
this way is just make this specifically
jewel and they're just making it so
attractive to the youth and now nicotine
use is skyrocketing because of Joel
there's an app for it when you have one
of those things you have an app that can
control how much smoke you get what yeah
and that's my jewel got so popular it's
got it out hopefully you can like hook
your kids on other things like sports or
something something that goes against
nicotine usage or vegetables and then
they're like you know what this thing
holds me back from being a good
basketball player and they'll have
another love that overrides it
[Music]
Oh